and that brings me to the next story and
a potential controversial subject civil
rights in an era of global pandemic what
you see now on your screens is a story
from u.s. news thousands March in Spain
on women's day despite coronavirus fears
March 8th the day before my birthday
tens of thousands of feminists in Spain
did not care ignored the warning to the
coronavirus many of them probably didn't
know and they marched side-by-side in a
massive crowd that is a huge crowd has a
huge crowd look at that picture and at
the time you know hindsight is 20/20 so
at the time they didn't really think
anything of it
Oh a couple hundred it was 600 or so
people who had the corona virus now
Spain is one of the hardest hit areas so
it's easy to look back and claim how you
know how stupid these people were and I
certainly think I think I think it is a
criticism you know this was this was at
a time when we already had China locking
down the entire theory of their country
and people were really concerned it was
gonna get bad but it's not just about
the feminists it's also about the
pastor's a Florida pastor was arrested
after ignoring coronavirus emergency
orders and bringing crowds to his church
there is you know a of studies a bunch
of polls should say came out showing the
left is more willing to adhere you know
to the warnings I guess and the right is
less likely to okay because many people
on the right feel that the media is just
trying to drum up fear for either
ratings or to make Trump look bad this
results in a lot of people on the right
downplaying things makes sense
so you know even though if the funny
thing is I feel like they'll sit that
the right also got roped into this they
got baited because Trump actually
started the task force in the
twenty-ninth banned travel on the thirty
on the 31st I think and the media was
still saying nah ignore Trump he's a
xenophobe he's overreacting it's not the
flu is worse and then finally when Trump
and his supporters started buying into
what they were saying saying oh we don't
think it's that bad the media flipped
and then start saying AHA we got you
yeah and then it made Trump double down
he's like that's the fake news and it
made sense because if you have a media
saying everything's fine and then you
say everything must be fine but then
they start accusing you saying
everything's wrong you're like I don't
believe you you're just lying to make me
look bad and so now we have this you
know basically this thing basically
happening
but it actually does get kind of a bit
more sad a pastor who claimed kovat 19
hysteria was a plot against Trump dies
from the virus so this one actually
makes me sad yep a more serious bummer
now actually died on the way home to he
wasn't even home he was back from from
the hospital yeah he was in New Orleans
and doing some sort of you know
spreading the word and he caught the
virus and was on his way back and like
halfway home he collapsed and went to a
hospital right there and I think it was
like oh yeah like that fast yeah so it's
really it really is a sad story yeah man
yeah so look you know we were talking
about this earlier and I was like you
know making fun of a large group of
feminists is like you know who's really
gonna complain it's like a group of
people is not an individual none of them
like necessarily lost their lives or
anything yeah but this is like a dude
and so this look kind of worries me that
if people are going to take it seriously
or they're gonna you know downplay it
and then they're gonna end up losing
their lives this makes me sad this is it
this is a human being that's an
individual who you know at least
according to this to Paseos had an
incorrect view of how serious this was
and how people take this stuff seriously
I don't know you want to read the story
and I mean no not really I it's we
pretty much covered it already it's
pretty it's pretty much a bummer I mean
he was basically believing the media or
not believe in the media like now
they're you know this is just some some
thing against Trump and Trump's telling
me it's okay so I'm gonna go out and
keep doing it and it you know believing
that the Lord was going to keep him
protected which is obviously not true or
like that other article we just had what
did what did the pastor rodney
howard-browne told his followers there
was a plan to shut down Christianity and
that God might replenish their low
supply of toilet paper it's just like is
that you know I almost don't believe it
though I got it I got to be serious it
does it's tough I believe it is tough
ability to be right but you know you
know what's crazy that same day that the
feminists marched is the same day I just
checked it out is the same day the
Smurfs gathering in France these people
man I had to look it up I was like no
way is it
at the same time it was right around our
birthday I'll tell people the Smurf
thing was because me right so so
actually in France the same day as these
this feminist gathering was the Guinness
world record of the largest Smurf
gathering of people dressed up as Smurfs
so and and sure enough to two or three
days later
Frances kovat 19 spices spiked up well
but the incubation periods a couple
weeks true that's a good point
all right and maybe it wasn't a day or
two later I don't know exactly but I
remember having conversation to you like
oh I saw Frances like spiking now and
I'm like hmm what happened recently oh
yeah there was that Smurf gathering and
it's like what is up with these these
people gathering it's like they didn't
believe it you know right like but I
don't you know I don't you can't blame
the media because the media flip-flops
sometimes they're saying it's crazy
sometimes they're saying Trump's lying
it's not so bad it's just no you know I
blame the media they flip-flop when it's
convenient so they can get traffic
that's good that way they can
simultaneous is a paradise and Los
Angeles sucks mice calm and sea vice
writing both articles yeah they do it
because they want to capture the entire
TV audience so then what ends up
happening is people don't trust the
media they assume everything the media
is saying is is a lie and then the so if
a story comes up it's actually important
they won't actually believe it right so
a lot of people end up not believing it
they'll fall off the feet of this but
I'm not super concerned about whether or
not people choose to believe the media
or not the bigger question here is
should the pastor be arrested for
telling his congregation to come
together should the feminists be you
know broken up should the should the
event be shut down because of the
coronavirus should people have a right
to peacefully assemble should people
have a right to go on Facebook and post
meme saying they don't think it's real I
can't say no yes people should always
have the rights but people should be
smart it's like it doesn't make sense to
be going out and when this is going on
it's like I don't understand why they
would want to still you know it's like
yes I you know coming together for a
read
you know like the feminist March makes a
lot more sense to me than the Smurfs
gathering you know it's like very easily
been postponed there seemed to be a lot
more people this was in Spain as that
where it was
yeah the feminist March yeah okay it's
like that was a lot of people you know I
wouldn't have expected that many people
in Spain you know it's like but I guess
so it's not totally the I'm sorry in a
pandemic but it was endemic at the time
Oh or actually was it I'm pretty sure
was yeah I'm pretty sure was you know
write writing about the Smurfs thing
like what are these people doing like or
it was an outbreak at least what do
let's figure out when the pandemic
actually was declared because it was
March 8th they went out they went out
protesting yeah well so here's the
bigger question you know Trump was
talking about hard quarantine us that's
freaking yeah yeah we're like whoa yeah
you freaked out there for a bit well but
I mean it about it for a good reason
yeah we're gonna what I'm gonna close
the bridges right how do we where do we
go
like what do we you know are we trapped
you know was through like the food
trucks is that the only thing that is
allowed to pass through so doctor foul
Qi and other medical experts talk to
Trump and said it was a bad idea so the
issue date wrong a strong travel
advisory because if they did announce a
hard quarantine people would flee this
state so fast they couldn't do anything
about it cause just pandemonium yeah
that's what I was thinking like if if
there was you know the National Guard on
the bridge and there was like I don't
know what that would entail like would
they just park a couple trucks and like
have it I mean just you know what you're
saying like turn around go back you know
like have left some sort of turn around
system but like if enough people wanted
to get over that bridge they're gonna
make it over that bridge I think we're
still close to that happening like China
locked everything down that's why you
saw the riots mm-hmm
so yeah if in China they're gonna ride
and flip over a police vehicle and bash
double shields well I feel people here I
mean I don't know for certain but
knowing the temperature in China like
not actual temperature but just like the
the environment of China CCP versus the
people basically it's just like we've
seen it in the past yes sorry well a lot
of the people in China are they're used
to this right the government will
oppress you can't anything about it in
the US were rebellious hard-headed fu to
the government B generation though what
generation in China is used to it you
know all of them I feels like there's
younger like some sort of young all
right all the whistleblowers are are
younger renovations they're not old
people they're younger people like us
they have access to meaning like
probably like in their 30s or 40s it
seems like you know they seem younger
you know but you know that's and those
are the people that I saw fighting you
know it wasn't a bunch of old people
fighting police it was like a younger
generation fighting alright so here's
here's a question first well I'll get to
I'll get to the serious question we have
we have another story here from BuzzFeed
they were opposed to government
surveillance then the corona virus
pandemic began as nations around the
world take on sweeping new powers to
fight the disease critics aren't sure
what necessary what's necessary and
what's too far I don't necessarily want
to read this but it's just I want to
highlight that the conversation is here
we are seeing an expansion of federal
authorities we are seeing in Maryland
one year in jail and a five thousand
dollar fine up to if you violate their
their stay at home order and they've
announced in the decree its indefinite
until they say so man in Virginia they
said until June 10th you know this is
all I see is like a lot of people even
people that I know I'm sure a lot of
people out there are staying in they are
abiding by the quarantine and like
trying to stay in and go only go out
when needed but then we got all these
stupid Spring Breakers and like you know
people gather in going like I have a lot
of friends in New York that are posting
pictures of the park and there's mad
people in the park yeah totally of
course no one cares and it's like
they're the reason the the people that
are going out to the parks I mean are
the reason that this is going on this is
getting worse and worse because them
just going let's just quarantine please
just stay inside that's not working
and so so what the only answer is hard
enforcement it's a violation of the
First Amendment
ah man it's you you you it's let's I'll
give you a scenario it's 10:00 a.m.
you're a knock on the door you walk to
the door open it up and there's a guy
and you know military uniform with his
hands behind his back next to him is a
doctor and he's got a needle and he
flicks it and he says mr. Kriegler
you're shot your arm please what do you
do do you say yes sir
please inject me with this unknown
foreign substance I'll just trust you or
do you say I'm not let you put that yeah
who are you you're not my doctor and you
know you I don't know you are I mean I
would definitely deny that because so so
if they're gonna do that it's gonna be
you know at a hospital or some sort of
like you know tenth it up let's say they
announce in order to lift the quarantine
I ones gotta get a vaccine and they get
you get a card in the mail and it says
you must arrive to the this you know
makeshift FEMA emergency camp okay at 10
a.m. you show up a bunch people in line
one at a time and they walk up they
prick you in the arms next person they
just keep giving everyone vaccines would
you would you walk in and just take the
shot from the government I think so I
don't know if I would I say that but
grudgingly because I yes I'm the same as
you like I want I I need to know
research I'm very I need to know what's
going on I need to have all the details
I want to see all the tests I want to
know that it's been proven right and
that it works you know and if I'm not
getting that I'm gonna be hesitant but
if every single person is getting it and
they're not giving me a choice it's like
what is the choice then right
you know that's authoritarianism I and
that's I know that's terrifying
I agree do you send your principles and
say like so here's the issue right I'm
because we talk to us but before I've
gotten a ton of vaccinations because I
when I would travel around like you got
to do it man you'd want to get yellow
fever or like typhus or something tough
so I got no problem I went to doctor I
was like give it to me
you know in the and you know it's crazy
is one of them I think it was the Hep A
shot okay goes in your skin like really
yeah not all the way it just like they
they go sideways into your skin and
that's to hurt he was like this one's
gonna hurt the most and I'm like all
right now I was like wow that didn't
hurt that bad so it's interesting though
that you would freely just take these
vaccines that have already been proven
when long standing right long odds of
data true right lots of data now now we
have a bumbling government it feels like
they have everything they can on this
because I still believe that they're
freaking out the the reason they I mean
one of the reasons because there's many
reasons I'm sure the freaking out is
because it's
the generation that's in charge right
right of course we're you know so it's
really trying to figure this out so I
think it's try it vaccine sooo let's put
another way let's say the government
showed up and badges verified you're
like it's very obvious of the government
and they said we want to take this pill
okay of hydroxychloroquine and this pill
of us ather my son right now would you
take it no I don't have diseases I don't
know no they said we've found it's it's
it's a prophylactic we want everyone to
take it and it'll protect you and this
is the official thing don't worry about
a vaccine just take these pills and
you're good to go and we're going
door-to-door to administer this ok can I
ask do they watch me or gonna pop it in
my mouth right they're like I'm in your
mouth take it alright put it in my mouth
no they want you to take it put it the
reason I'm asking it this way is it in
the closet for if I do get it the reason
I'm asking this way is because what
people need to understand about my
reticence is that the media just spent
the past several weeks telling me that
these treatments were dangerous and will
kill you that's a good point so now if
the government says hey it actually does
work I'm gonna be like I don't know
BuzzFeed told me it'll kill me I'm not
gonna take that pill you nuts
and it's BuzzFeed's fault not mine I
don't believe the media and hopefully
right a lot of people I mean seriously a
lot of people are learning that the
media is crazy and not paying attention
look a ton of sites told me that the
drug headed by Trump will kill you and I
just heard a story about a man in
Arizona who took the drug and died and
they're gonna try and explain to me it's
not true and I'm gonna be like blame
BuzzFeed yeah blame blame blame these
these sites that work we're lying this
whole time that he took the drug I could
say in quotes because it wasn't this is
this is a real conundrum though because
there there look men there there's a lot
of people who are anti-vaxxers for
really strange reasons like they see
memes and they believe fake things yeah
there are a lot of people who ask
legitimate questions and gets smeared in
the press as being anti vex like they're
one of the things that comes up is they
ask I don't think my child should be
forced by the government to medicate in
order to go to school well ok that's an
interesting point you can you can
believe that vaccines work and they're
very important but not like the idea of
the government forcing you to medicate
ok I certainly like the idea of
government the government mandated
medication that sounds insane
it's like 1984 or worse yeah the
government doctor shows up here's your
pill for the day not interested so the
challenge now is
we have a pandemic yeah people are dying
yes the vaccine sounds like it'd be
pretty good thing I would like to not
get the corona virus and have my lungs
explode right yeah but it's a question
of if we just give in today what does
that mean for tomorrow if we just say
like I don't care if the government
force doesn't medicate then at what
point are they just like it's a normal
thing everyone medicates take your pills
shut up and get your chip when you're
born yep because it's normal you know
thing I don't think the chip thing will
ever really catch on though it's it's
it's it's like I feel like the the
implant chip idea which exists and it's
not a conspiracy theory there are
companies and people actually
voluntarily get the chips in their hands
it's it's like a you're like you know
I'm back to the future in Part two when
they go to the future and they see you
like his the hologram of the shark and
like the self-lacing shoes it's an
archaic view of what the future would be
what what didn't they predict cell
phones they hit a hoverboard because
they had skateboards and they're like
what if a skateboard could float and so
they imagine that we know we've amended
cellphones and now we can have access to
the summation of human knowledge
anywhere we are and use it to look at
pictures of cats and argue with
strangers yeah but we don't have
self-lacing clothes I think the chip in
people's skin is basic is it's it's the
equivalent of that it's like 20 years
ago they were like what if you had a
chip that could do these things and now
we have cell phones and more like I can
just night waited actually build the
shoes I know I know they're a little
expensive not worth it but I can just
wave my phone over the door door opens
right yeah it's funny that you mentioned
smart phones and chips because in China
they are requiring you to have a little
green bar code before you go back to
work
really what's a little green bar code
it's on your phone scan it I saw them I
literally saw a video of them sorry but
what does that do what it tells them
that you're cleared you went to the
doctor
you got the okay and they take your
temperature manners mm-hmm dude I would
not want to leave me a sign as an
authoritarian state surprising
smartphone and we're also seeing how it
doesn't really work it doesn't it's the
system can only handle so much but I
will say a surveillance state makes it
substantially more likely the
authoritarian regime stays in power
that's a good point if people can't
assemble and communicate without being
shut down yeah there you go so that's
why we have the First Amendment right
the right to peaceably assemble so we
can talk about these ideas and push back
but if they're surveilling us the moment
you send a text message where you're
like I don't like this they come for you
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you